hey guys I'm Ryan Wright and I'm Jerry
welcome two reasons to see when we give
you reasons to see and maybe not to see
the interview so let's hang out we're
gonna be nice today because we're so we
saw this controversial film you know the
most controversial movie America has
ever had to deal with I mean there are
other countries there are other
controversial films none that had to be
really pooled because a country was
threatening to go to war with us that's
true spoilers - by the way if you
haven't seen the movie it's on YouTube
so stop watching our video our G much
every event I think it's really cool
before having a movie I think it's
[ __ ] cool that it's actually got this
release because it had all this
controversy about it then they pulled it
out of the theaters and then they were
like we might not do anything with it
and then they put it on YouTube and Xbox
and stuff I'm like thinking there they
might even make more money they got all
this hype towards it because of all of
this stuff if we were having this
conversation last week it's like because
of all this stuff if they ever release
it it's gonna make of course like it's
oh yeah dude it's it's gonna become a
cult hit like even after watching it I
could totally see how it's gonna be one
of those movies that is gonna have a bad
base that really does dig it a lot maybe
we may be interesting so we have a
middle middle middle a little [ __ ] thank
you so we have a little disagreement
going on here makes for a good show yeah
for us to disagree every once in a while
I mean like it'll be mentioned in
conversation I don't know if it'll be a
cult hit as a movie it wasn't like it's
a great film that got pulled it has like
a 50 percent on Rotten Tomatoes it's a
split audience and so that's why I think
that split of the people who do like it
are gonna be like kind of loyal to it
and defending it and stuff it doesn't
have the typical characteristics of a
cult hit now I can see what you say it's
like I could see the possibility but I I
can't honestly be like that's gonna be a
cult hit anyway
nothing about that let's talk about the
actual movie um I thought it was funny I
look it's funny it's a comedy that's all
that counted I think if North Korea
actually saw this movie they would have
been like it's a little [ __ ] up but
it's clearly over the top that's
insulting I mean so it's it's mean it is
like they do kill them by the end of it
especially if it is such a thing more
it's like if kim jeong-hoon and and the
people take him that seriously like they
imagined they would be horribly offended
but this is one of those things where
it's just like I'm not surprised at all
just having seen the trailer like if it
is North Korea LA and there's argument
over if it even is them for real I get
how they if they would have been mad at
because when I saw the trailer the first
time I was like how did this like I'm
kind of surprising that they were
allowed to make this movie because what
if somebody actually gets mad about this
it has those elements but I don't think
the elements were strong enough in this
film like what's the word that people
are using for a satire kind of comedy
it's not like it doesn't really possess
that yeah I mean it's not incredibly
intelligent it doesn't have like a
really smart subtext no it's like an
argue that scene America actually has a
lot of brain underneath it but like no
this film is just they obviously what to
dick jokes though I thought it's a
really silly film
you can't take it seriously at all it's
funny to see a movie so controversial
and when you watch it you're like this
is just a funny film I mean I get from
North Korea's perspective okay enough
about the politics let's just look at
this movie for itself the thing I walked
away most from is James Franco's
performance because it had so much hit
and miss but when it hit it [ __ ] me
hate you know like yeah that's what I
loved about him and you kind of needed
his performance to be like that because
what if it was just as like trying to be
as like sincere realist a throw goons
because if you're doing a story about
assassinating kim jeong-hoon you don't
want to piss people off too much like
you need it to be so over-the-top it's
like at times he kind of was a lot of
the time he'd seem like he was playing a
comedy you know yeah sometimes it really
worked it was really funny sometimes
that
thing I go back and forth along with
this movie for a lot of not so much the
supporting characters but Seth Rogen and
James Franco are really weird to me cuz
like this movie is full of moments where
both of them really work and it's full
of moments where both of them pulled me
out of the movie with whatever's going
yeah because this movie is sort of a
tonal Frankenstein's monster because
it's like sometimes they're matched and
their relationship makes sense then
sometimes James Frank it was so much
more ridiculous than the movie is
whatever James Franco is away and Seth
Rogen's alone then all of a sudden he's
not the straight man anymore and now
he's funny
I had trouble believing a lot of things
but but in isolated scenes when it
worked I was still laughing at that
stuff honestly to me it was just a fun
comedy like it was nothing more nothing
less
it's just a silly ass film and even felt
like with the script and the direction
of it that they were kind of just having
a fun time on set you know like yeah
sometimes they might have been having
more fun than the audience at man I
think that's a big thing about this
movie for me because like at the end of
the day it's like if you if you don't
care about you know like critical
discourse like yeah by the end of it I'm
sitting back in my chair and grinning
about it because it is fun but at a
certain point of like guys could you at
least make this kind of cohesive I can
suspend my disbelief for a lot of things
but half an hour into this movie I was
like I've been killed
so like hundred times by now like not
even like my real-world logic just by
like what this movie is giving me I
already don't believe they have not been
murdered Oh what Oh sometimes I love the
opening scene with Eminem oh yeah that
was [ __ ] hilarious I was watching
that to the point where I was like man I
hope this is true somehow I really want
this to be a real thing if anyone knows
anything about Eminem everyone knows
that the accusations of him being
homophobic yeah and you do that role it
was so fun
he was more real than James Franco ever
was in this entire movie yeah he was so
committed to the [ __ ] just the way
everyone reacted and how launched him
like I was so glad that he was on board
to do that part of the movie yeah it's
like that scene worked out because it
seemed like James Franco is so
over-the-top but Eminem's seemed like so
intent on just letting people know
what's going on with him to the point
where even though he was pretty real
about it like a camera
ra's is still serving and when that
moment comes out when he says he's gay I
had the same reaction as the character I
was like wait a minute did write and
then immediately when I'm thinking
tonight hear that right it cuts to them
in the board in the control room being
like wait a minute go but what did he
just saying I think because of such a
really funny opening scene that's why it
was always able to hook me back in
eventually honestly I think 3/4 of this
film is good maybe I'll meet you at half
okay okay because I think Act one is
good I think the first act of act 2 is
okay the finale I enjoy I feel like
every other scene is good guy who plays
kim jeong-hoon
I thought he was great ya know he was
good sometimes his dialogue comment just
was like typical comedy crap to me like
the slang in a car yeah that [ __ ]
honestly annoys me whatever I hear now
it annoys me in this movie actually like
this movie got that balance for me I
think as good as any movie will because
it was like he was so good at selling
those lines so that while I was like uh
I was still like well I kind of believed
it coming out of your mouth the dude
turn it into a character yeah he didn't
like actually you know just go on set
and do a [ __ ] impression of the guy
yeah like he made it a full-on character
you know gasps wild child and I grown
man's body and stuff you know like I
thought it was kind of smart how they
had James Franco's character and having
kim jeong-hoon
like having them bond with like their
childhood past and stuff and their
personalities and everything like I
thought that was kind of clever because
it makes sense yeah it made sense and it
made the story more interesting when
things played out like when I came time
for the interview no you think it was
just gonna be something typical where he
goes in there any [ __ ] rocks it but
then he gets the puppy is so funny how
he just gives them a puppy it's like
[ __ ] up with James Franco's original
intent I thought that scene was good
because it also showcased like serious
acting of the guy plays kim jong yeah
well that's another thing this movie is
good at I think that it is good at but
you spend various scenes wondering does
he really like Dave right now or Z or is
he honey [ __ ] him and yeah
they eventually clear that up yeah yeah
I think is interesting that they at
least made me wonder like who can I
trust you know I thought when okay they
introduced kim jeong-hoon
I felt like oh [ __ ] things are about to
get really interesting and then things
kind of got a little boring Oh like
after they were done partying after that
it just started dragging for me and
really slowing down there's stuff that
they cut to that I enjoyed like I was
liking the Seth Rogen story developing
with that asian chick that was about the
only other thing they cut but I think
this movie has scenes that are filled
with tons of like really laughs out loud
moments that opening scene I loved all
the Lord of the Rings references I
thought they were all really funny I
chuckled like they were I like five or
six laugh out loud moments but like oh I
had a lie I was amused most of the time
mmm that's Ferriss it's like kind of be
like I like being in a party and listen
to your friend tell an absurd story
that's kind of too long so like
occasionally like that that's good okay
it was a little interesting to me when
violence kicked in that's the thing
about a lot of Seth Rogen comedies I
noticed is that when violence happens
they make him like violent like even
pineapple be arrested it with violence
and like this movie certainly does it
cuz it was crazy as they throw in like
real violence at one point and then make
it look real and then back it up with
him they follow with a really funny
moment they would hit you and throw you
off and then follow it up with something
really funny like when the guy's head
gets when they can when they shoot and
the guy who's dying shoots the other
soldier in the head
the way James Franco's crying about it
or when Seth Rogen gets his finger bit
off a hint it just screams in such a
funny way even the [ __ ] like tank
crushing those people is so violent yeah
he's like you're not expecting it from
from a comedy yet whether or not those
moments work like in the course the
actual movie what I do admire about
these guys as a team is that they are
willing to go there like this is the end
and pineapple Express it's like well you
went there that is honestly what made me
laugh when I was watching the violence
cuz like Seth Rogen gets his finger bit
off then he bites off a guy's finger
then the guy by topping another finger
yeah like it's it's it's a practical
effects very easy
you look rather real the end of the day
it's like it's a little ridiculous and
it's something like family guy would
even do yeah but you know because it's
real life it's a little bit more
disturbing well yeah and I think their
hearts in the right place with those
jokes and and why they're funny this
movie sort of full of things that I just
wish had been handled more cohesively
there are a lot of things that I think
on their own are funny and I even
appreciate a lot of the characters on
their own it's like thinking back on it
it's lame-o you just want to give James
Franco a big hug but at the same time
like just watching them play out as a
movie it doesn't ever but I kinda like I
like actually how it felt
I'm even I felt like there was a life to
it still which life did and which is
something that I think a lot of movies
just miss is having a life to it there
was an energy about it you know there's
a spontaneity vibe about it to me like
yeah I'm just having fun with it and
then like cuz they made this ridiculous
thing just believable enough but to have
it progressed like but at the end of the
day if it felt more believable and more
real but then I think we'd even have
more of a problem with all the politics
stuff going on maybe and man for me was
just a tonal thing it was like okay
there was never like the tone was never
consistent and like the rules it's one
of the things was like it it doesn't
really draw the rules of its universe
clearly enough and then it doesn't play
by them anyway I kept getting distracted
by things like that so it kept being
like oh yeah this scene works and then
the next thing I'd be like oh yeah I
have pulled out it was like I saw the
reviews and [ __ ] I was expecting
something like really bad it's C way I
felt about the Green Hornet like I was
expecting something really bad and like
while I can see the things that don't
work are quite evident the things that
Michael Matic yeah that's my girl won't
worry about any of it I'm not like oh
but I feel that what I liked about it is
what I really walked away thinking about
every movie has pros and cons what are
you walking away really thinking about
and I'm walking away thinking about like
I laughed pretty good amount of time so
at the end of the day I enjoyed it I
only got
little bored for a while but most of it
I was I was amused throughout that was
me like this is one of those movies
where I look back and I'm like yeah I'm
mildly enjoyed that like I have no no
ill-will against it like I'd watch it
again on TV if it was on late at night
or something anyway yeah I would say
we're critics on this episode so let's
uh let's give a rating ooh laughs out
loud occasional laughs it's the reason
to see the interview I would say
curiosity is the reason it's Andy and
and like if you like these guys like cuz
if you don't like them you're not gonna
like it smooth well thank you guys for
listening to us if you're new to the
channel you can subscribe to the real
rejects and you can check out Jerry's
playlist reasons to Jerry or he does his
little solo reviews and you could also
check out my playlist of my movie
reviews but then you can check out more
reasons to see if you want to see more
of us talking together but if you want
to see a trailer reaction review show
then you can click on that playlist too
we have short films and sketches and we
have a lot of hot girls come on the
channel and we're doing good and it
seems like happy holidays happy Honda
days